this is a straight up a movie yeah it's
beautiful what do you uh what do you
what do you think is the meaning of life
what do I think is the meaning of life
I think it's a good thing to ask while
we're listening we're watching a bunch
of cowboys ride
to the woods I think nothing in life
matters except for love and human
connection
[Music]
like nothing else is really all that
important
like I think when you look back on life
you look back on the moments that you
shared with other people How Deeply you
love them How Deeply you felt things
I think all of that is important
everything else is just noise
I agree this is really beautiful is it
the seasons are changing
yeah before our eyes
what do you think is the meaning of life
how good you can ride a horse
how pretty you look in a cowboy hat
that's probably it
um so it's not wearing
shorts Barefoot on a beach
on a horse
when the feeling strikes you yeah
a ridiculous photo of me it's my
favorite photo I'm a horse I've ever
seen of a person
yeah it's a fabulous photo the funny
thing is there's a bunch of shirtless
versions of that there's shirtless
versions it was like you know almost
like ridiculous because I rode the horse
shirtless but then I put on a shirt this
is like too ridiculous to take a picture
of like what are you doing it was it was
cool like riding a horse on Sand is is a
different experience
it's like looking out over the ocean
it's cool it's an incredible feeling why
did you just shoot a gun
[Laughter]
this is how
okay all bad things happen this is why
we can't have nice things I think this
is
a good place to end it yeah I think so
too
uh we'll game should we play next time
um you have ideas
maybe we'll play GTA could be
good thought
what's your big takeaway from this
journey we took together
um
do you like to get I love the game
I love it too but it's also like it's
almost nostalgic
yeah
that would be fun nostalgic like
personally for you like Yeah from a
different life oh I see you used to play
this I thought you meant like it takes
me back it takes me back I used to my
old days when I used to ride horses at
summer camp me too
you're shirtless the Mexico trip
the things
These Eyes I've seen